hey 42 here the assassination
of john fitzgerald kennedy in november
of 1963
was one of the 20th century's most
defining moments
it was one of those rare where were you
when it happened kind of events
like 911 and the moon landing the
president of the united states of
america
is one of the most powerful individual
human beings on the entire planet
but for jfk that power was taken away in
a fraction of a second
by the slightest squeeze of a trigger
finger but as well as being one of
history's most shocking
incidents jfk's assassination is
notorious
for another reason it's one of the
biggest conspiracy
magnets of all time seriously
if conspiracy theories were iron filings
the murder of jfk would be a giant slab
of pure neodymium
amongst these masked ranks of conspiracy
theories is the idea that jfk
was killed by a high-tech device
supplied by the leader of an alien
alliance
a suggestion the murder weapon wasn't a
high-powered rifle
but instead a weaponized umbrella
and that woody harrelson's dad did it
as is the case with the vast majority of
conspiracy theories
most of the alternative explanations
surrounding the jfk assassination
are utterly and completely mental
but unlike most conspiracy theories the
official account of what happened that
day
seems to be similarly far-fetched and
considering the profile of the event
we're talking literally one of the most
famous things ever to happen
in the recent history of our species the
sheer amount of confusion
misinformation and subterfuge
surrounding the assassination
is astonishing okay so let's start at
the beginning
on the 22nd of november 1963 in the
early afternoon
john f kennedy's presidential motorcade
was driving for the city of dallas
unlike a few other notable examples jfk
was an extremely popular president for
the most part
and ecstatic unlockers lined the streets
just to get a glimpse of him
it was a sunny day in texas and earlier
that morning
kennedy had ordered his limousines top
to be left off
so as to give the crowds a better view
of him i'd say that was a decision he
lived to regret
but uh yeah
kennedy and his wife jacqueline were
smiling and waving as the cars trundled
through dealey plaza
on their way through dallas it was a
beautiful sunny
and happy day until all of a sudden
it wasn't
[Music]
it's thought three shots were fired in
total
though some claim it was four at least
one shot missed
one took the president high up on the
back exiting through his throat
and another struck him in the head in a
blow so devastating
fragments of kennedy's scalp brain and
skull
were later found spattered on the bonnet
of the next car
along in the motorcade and on the
officers riding motorcycles to either
side
kennedy wouldn't be pronounced dead for
another 30 minutes
but there is never any chance he could
have survived at 1
40 pm exactly one hour and 10 minutes
after the shooting
a man named lee harvey oswald was
arrested
and charged with the murder of the
president of the united states of
america
he was also charged with the murder of
one jd tippet
a police officer oswald had shot in cold
blood in the intervening time between
the president's assassination
and his own capture oswald was taken
into custody
where he was questioned several times
over the next 48 hours
he strenuously denied all charges
leveled against him
claiming he'd been framed but he would
never have the chance to argue his case
in court
because two days after his arrest whilst
he was being escorted through the
basement of dulles police headquarters
he was shot and killed by nightclub
owner jack ruby
who stepped out from the crowd and fired
before anyone could react tv cameras had
been rolling at the time and oswald's
murder was broadcast around america
becoming the first ever murder shown on
live tv
though oswald was no longer around for
questioning the official story that
emerged in the aftermath of the shooting
was crystal clear oswald acting
completely alone
and with no accomplices of any kind shot
and killed president kennedy from a
sniper's nest
on the sixth floor of the texas school
book depository
which overlooked daley plaza by the way
here's a little-known piece of movie
trivia for you
the specific section of dealey plaza
jfk's motorcade was driving along when
he was shot
is called elm street a name that's no
doubt familiar to you from a certain
famous horror movie franchise and it
turns out
that's no coincidence most people assume
elm street was chosen as the setting for
the film to give off a
small town america kind of vibe elm
street is the sixth most common street
name in the us
if you discount numbered streets with
over 5000 of them spread around the
country
but in reality director wes craven
decided to title his seminal horror film
a nightmare on elm street in honor of
the jfk shooting
claiming that was the spot where all
innocence ended in 1963
with the loss of innocence being a key
theme in the film
oddly enough the words elm street are
never actually spoken in the film
despite being such an iconic part of the
title
anyway despite oswald's claims he'd been
set up
the evidence seemed pretty conclusive he
worked at the book depository
and most witnesses agreed the shots had
come from that direction
his boss testified that oswald was
carrying a long paper bag when he
arrived at work that morning
at the time oswald had claimed it
contained curtain rods
but the bag was later recovered and
markings inside suggested
it had indeed concealed a weapon oswald
was a self-proclaimed marxist with a
pro-communist background
and had defected to the soviet union
four years prior to the assassination
he was also an ex-marine and a
proficient shot
and his actions directly after the
assassination fleeing the scene
of the crime didn't exactly make him
look innocent either
so putting all of that together it does
kind of sound like an open and shut case
doesn't it oswald's political leanings
gave him a motive
he had the expertise and the opportunity
required
to carry out the crime and he was
spotted carrying what very probably was
a weapon to work in the morning of the
assassination
the warring commission a committee set
up in late 1963
to piece together the circumstances
surrounding the assassination
came to the inevitable conclusion that
lee harvey oswald
acting alone shot and killed the
president
of the united states of america
and yet plenty of people think
that version of events which the u.s
government has largely stuck to ever
since
is a lie or if not quite a lie
that it doesn't represent the whole
truth and when i say plenty of people
i'm not talking about a bunch of nutters
in those dusty corners of the internet
usually reserved for flat earthers and
lizard men lunatics
those guys think jfk conspiracy theories
are way too mainstream
no it isn't just conspiracy theory
fanatics who are suspicious
of the circumstances surrounding
kennedy's assassination
a 2013 gallup poll found that more than
of americans believe the official
version of events
is false and the similar poll conducted
around the turn of the millennium
suggested it was as much as eighty
percent of the population
as it happens on this occasion that
mistrust is very well placed
why because we know for a fact
there is at least one genuine conspiracy
connected to the case
a secret plot to conceal information
about what really happened
before during and after the
assassination
of jfk and this little subterfuge wasn't
carried out by
a person or persons responsible for the
actual shooting either
no it was a deliberate campaign
undertaken
by the cia and endorsed by people
in the very highest echelons of the us
government
we're talking top secret documents that
were destroyed
physical evidence that mysteriously went
missing
and witnesses and whistleblowers who
were discreetly silenced
now the idea that u.s government and cia
were involved in some kind of
secret plot may sound like a big claim
and it is but don't worry you don't have
to take my word for it
because the cia's very own chief
historian concluded
that's exactly what happened in a now
declassified report
written in 2013. the report doesn't tell
us anything much about what really
happens that day in 1963
but it does confirm the cia knew a lot
more than they ever let on
and that the intelligence agency
willfully withheld
important information from the warren
commission that would almost
certainly have changed both the
direction
and the outcome of its investigations
now admittedly this declassified cia
report
did claim it was merely a benign
cover-up
their word not mine designed to better
represent what they considered
the best truth which was that oswald
acted completely alone in the
assassination of the president
but a benign cover-up is still a
cover-up
and the smoke and mirrors this
subterfuge created
have if anything only serve to add fuel
to this raging conspiracy theory bonfire
with a lot of popular conspiracy
theories you find yourself
questioning the sanity of those naive
enough to call themselves believers
i mean how can anyone really truly think
the earth is flat
but in this case it's exactly the
opposite
you kind of have to question the sanity
of those who don't think there's some
kind of conspiracy relating to the
assassination of jfk
after all the cia literally admitted to
having created one
at this point you might be wondering why
the cia was so keen to promote the idea
oswald was the shooter and that he had
no accomplices
is it possible they were trying to
suppress a much less palatable
truth after all the cia the dallas
police force
and even vice presidents lyndon b
johnson
all feature prominently in the various
conspiracy theories surrounding this
case
maybe but there are a couple of slightly
less
out there motives for the cover-up that
are probably more likely
the first was purely political if oswald
was acting on someone else's orders
that could have led to some very
unpleasant consequences
if a foreign power had been implicated
for example
it would have been seen as an act of war
very likely forcing the us into a
military response
that might have had devastating
implications for the entirety of the
human race
this all took place smack bang in the
middle of the cold war remember
the second reason to hide certain truths
about what really happened that day
is even simpler the cia were engaging in
a spot of good old-fashioned arse
covering
you see if oswald was a lone lunatic
as the cia wanted people to believe a
madman who woke up in the morning and
thought to himself
you know what i don't much like that
john kennedy
then preventing the assassination would
have been next to impossible
if on the other hand oswald was part of
a wider conspiracy to kill the president
if he had known links to groups who
wanted to do both president kennedy
and the u.s harm if in short he was
blinking
brightly on the cia's radar prior to the
assassination
well then it was a truly monumental
blunder
on the part of the u.s intelligence
services that the assassination
was ever allowed to happen i mean
the president's open-topped car drove
directly past the guy's place of work
you'd think that might have rung a few
alarm bells if it had been known
oswald was a threat and so the now
well-documented benign cover-up took
place
the cia withheld their information and
the warren commission went ahead without
the full facts at their disposal
their report was released in the autumn
of 1964 giving the public their first
opportunity to pick over the official
version of events
with a fine-toothed comb and it didn't
take long for people to start finding
inconsistencies for starters witness
testimonies taken in the aftermath of
the shooting were kind of
all over the place 104 people
heard the shots that killed president
kennedy
52 thought they came from the direction
of the texas
school book depository but a substantial
32 percent
put the shooter is standing on the now
infamous grassy knoll at the side of the
road
where conspiracy theorists have long
speculated
a second shooter may have been
positioned
nine percent picked a different location
entirely
skeptics have investigated the timing of
events too
the weapon used in the shooting was a
6.5 millimeter carcano
a bolt-action carbine according to the
report
all three shots loosed at kennedy were
fired in around
five to seven seconds oswald was known
to be a good shot
but some have questioned whether he
really could have been capable of firing
free shots
with a bolt-action weapon at that speed
and with such accuracy then there was
the information reported about the shots
themselves
you see kennedy wasn't the only man in
the vehicle who was wounded that day
texas governor john connolly who was
sitting directly in front of the
president
was also hit he survived but suffered a
fractured rib
a punctured lung a shattered wrist and a
bullet wound in his leg
but the warren commission concluded that
the bullet that hit
president kennedy in the upper back and
exited through his throat
also caused a wound suffered by governor
connolly
like all of them if that were true
this one tenacious bullet powered its
way through no fewer
than 15 layers of clothing and seven
layers of skin
creating four entry wounds and three
exit wounds in the process
not to mention traveling through nearly
40 centimeters of muscle tissue
smashing 10 centimeters of connolly's
rib
and shattering the radius bone in his
right forearm
before finally making itself at home in
his
thigh despite this ordeal
the bullet was found largely intact just
lying on a gurney in the hospital where
kennedy and connolly were taken after
the attack
no one could even be sure if it was
connolly's gurney
yeah it isn't too hard to see why
conspiracy theorists sunk their teeth
into that one
skeptics refer to this warren commission
explanation
as the magic bullet theory and they
believe
there's a much simpler explanation for
this hard to believe bullet behavior
there was another shooter presence that
day firing from a different angle
altogether
grassy knoll anyone it's worth pointing
out that whilst interesting
no so-called inconsistencies in the
warren commission's report
really prove anything sure it's odds
that different people heard gunshots
from different directions that day
but eyewitness testimony and ear witness
testimony for that matter
have never been a sure thing and most of
those who heard the gunshots didn't even
recognize them for what they were at the
time
with many thinking someone had set off
firecrackers
it's the same thing when it comes to
questions over oswald's ability to have
made those shots
as quickly as he apparently did there's
no denying that if the warren report
is correct oswald fired faster
and truer than would have been possible
for most people
even experienced users of firearms but
oswald was a marine and other weapons
experts have been able to reproduce
both the speed and accuracy he showed
that day
with the same weapon he used even the
so-called magic
bullet theory is the subject of a huge
amount of debate
for every person who claims no bullet
could have caused so much damage to two
different
people and survive to tell the tale
you'll find
another equally credible expert he'll
tell you
that crazy shot wasn't just possible
it was exactly the outcome expected
considering the relative positions of
the free men
oswald jfk and connolly at the time of
the shooting
when the warren commission report was
first released its conclusions were
widely believed
but as more and more voices began to
call into question its findings
the government decided something had to
be done
in 1976 a new investigation was launched
by the house of representatives select
committee on assassinations
to look into both kennedy's murder and
that of martin luther king jr
this new investigation took two years
and it came to several conclusions that
differed from the warren commissions
the most interesting of which was that
at least two gunmen fired on john f
kennedy
one of whom was oswald and one whose
identity was unknown
who probably fired from the grassy knoll
[Music]
it sounded like a big step forward for
conspiracy theorists
until it transpired that the key piece
of evidence leading the committee to
this conclusion
an audio recording taken during the
assassination
had likely been misinterpreted
unsurprisingly these questionable
findings
didn't do much to quieten the conspiracy
chatter
people wanted to know more and focus
soon turns to the large number of
unreleased classified files related to
the case
over the years pressure to make those
files public continued to grow
bolstered by the premiere of oliver
stone's 1991 film
jfk which ended with a message to
audiences to ask
congress to release all classified
records
relating to the assassination eventually
that pressure told and in 1992
the president's john f kennedy
assassination records collection act was
passed setting a 25-year deadline for
the release of all those documents
that deadline was reached in october of
when around 3 000 files were made public
the declassified documents contained a
huge amount of info
some of which was already known some of
which had long been suspected
and some of which was totally new they
also laid bare the cia's benign cover-up
for all to see
we now know lee harvey oswald had indeed
been on the cia's radar in the lead up
to the assassination
in fact he'd been under heavy
surveillance with some of his phone
calls being recorded
and pictures taken of him outside the
soviet embassy
he also had links to cuba and a memo
from j edgar hoover head of the fbi at
the time
even showed oswald had been overheard
threatening to kill the u.s
president during a trip to mexico he
took just weeks before the assassination
so yeah it seems the u.s intelligence
services
really did have all the information they
should have needed
to make sure lee javier's world was
nowhere near president kennedy
on that fateful day in dallas let alone
staring down at him through the science
of a high-powered carbine
perhaps unsurprisingly these revelations
have done nothing to quell one of the
biggest conspiracy theories of them all
that the cia was somehow involved in the
assassination
which admittedly does seem like a bit of
a stretch
but then again they weren't averse to
trying to bump off other world leaders
so i guess you never know also releasing
the kennedy files was information about
several attempts planned by the cia to
assassinate cuban leader
fidel castro one of which would have
seen them team up with the mafia
speaking of the mafia jack ruby the
nightclub owner who shot and killed
oswald live on television
was known to have connections to the
criminal underworld and he murdered the
one and only suspect in jfk's
assassination
ruby claimed he'd done it to spare
jackie kennedy the ordeal
of having to sit through oswald's trial
and perhaps that's true
but some people believe ruby had really
been sent
to silence oswald before he said too
much
or perhaps before he was able to prove
his innocence
[Music]
and that kind of thing pretty much sums
up the whole sorry story
no matter which way you turn in this
case there are odd connections and
strange coincidences examine any one
aspect of the assassination
closely enough and you're likely to come
away with more questions than
answers take kennedy's autopsy for
example
there are numerous reports from medical
staff at the parkland memorial hospital
that suggests a large portion of the
back of the president's skull
was missing when the body arrived and
yet
the official photos from the autopsy
show kennedy's head
was intact some say the wound was
concealed because it represented
evidence kennedy was shot from the front
and not from behind suggesting another
shooter
and others say the medical staff simply
got it wrong
2017's declassified documents did
contain a few other choice bombshells by
the way
like for example the fact that a threat
on lee harvey oswald's life
was called into the cia the day before
he was fatally shot and killed
by jack ruby and that the soviets seemed
to have believed kennedy had been
assassinated
in a plot involving his vice president
lyndon b
johnson who himself suggested in later
life that the hit was linked to the
vietnam war
this is normally the part of the video
where i say the plot thickens
but in this case the plot is already a
block of solid concrete so
dense it's unlikely anyone will ever be
able to reach the kernel of truth
hidden inside so are we any closer to
knowing the whole truth
and nothing but the truth about the
assassination of jfk
no no we are not in fact
i don't know about you but i'm more
confused than when i started
one thing we can pretty much say for
sure is that there's more to the
assassination of john f kennedy than
meets the eye
and that's the public have never quite
been given the full story
that view is backed up by the fact
former us president donald trump
made a last-minute decision to withhold
around 300 files
that were due to be released back in
2017 after pressure from the cia
amongst others so as for which of the
hundred or so theories about what really
happened that day you should believe
your guess is as good as mine thanks for
watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you